I don't know if you remember our last
interview that we did about six months
ago yep
but it went down well we had a lot of
great feedback and well has so much has
changed since then it would be great to
find ski perspective on a few things so
that's great so firstly how have you
been what have you been up to over the
last few months what's happening well I
have been doing what I love doing which
is researching and teaching I have done
much more online than usual yeah we have
done gosh
probably a hundred interviews in the
last two and half months that's crazy so
it was at March to March April May June
yeah about a hundred interviews and I've
done seven breakthrough experiences to
prophecy you seven-day programs in the
one five day program and get ready to do
another eight breakthrough this weekend
and then a whole lot of webinars just on
a whole lot of podcast and webinars and
interviews so yeah that is that now
running online yep we're actually doing
it online and it's doing great they're
coming in from all over the world so I
can't complain and did you previously
run that online I would we just started
doing it no we did it online I would I
flew in from Tokyo we were filming a
movie there and we I flew in from Tokyo
and I landed and we had planned on
having a break 2 on the day 2 days
beforehand they said well we're now not
allowed to have gatherings so in two
days we created the online version and
we had a bit of fallout but we did it
and the feedback from that was great so
that it's crescendoed since yeah so
we've been busy and now we've got the
blessings of reaching people that
normally would be able to fly and get in
now we're able to do it this way where
the numbers have gone up so I can't
complain we we've been busier than we've
ever been him and you know st. Corona is
helping us in many ways as well I mean I
teach as well I've got training a
training company what do you think of
online learning compared to physical
learning because I always was under the
impression I used to feel like I don't
want to teach online I love meeting
people I think when you're in the boom
the energy the buzz I never wanted to go
online I've been forced to go online
join lockdown so I've also been working
with sleep training programs online from
a learning perspective how does it
compare
I think there's advantages and
disadvantages when I'm in front of large
audience the people in the front I get
to interact with more than the people
way in the back when I'm on zoom for
instance I can have up to you know five
hundred people or whatever and I can
have them all equal so they can come
right up to the surface and I can talk
to them to interact with them engage
with them and I can put there's lots
advantages there's less cost on on
transportation hotels venues food and
and on paperwork and manuals and all
that this there's there's benefits it
keeps the cost down and it's there's
disadvantages I don't get to interact
with them so I think overall I'm pleased
I can't complain I still love going out
and doing live seminars impressive
presentations and I will continue to do
that second the flights are open and the
venues are open but I will do both I
will not throw this away now what we've
learned here we'll do both will probably
live film and allow people from around
the world to come in at the same time
doing live programs so I I think that
there's just like anything else that's
got advantages and disadvantages and
it's wise to see both sides and
resilient ly adapt and do whatever
allows you to serve the mission yeah 100
interviews over the last few months yeah
at least a hundred I mean I think I've
done a already common things that keep
coming up I mean are there questions
that you just sick of my it's like
Samuel please don't ask me this because
I've been asked the under times no
actually I've had programs in India and
Thailand and Sri Lanka and and UK and
Australia and New Zealand you know all
over the world and they all are varied
I can't say that there's always the same
question it's a few but I mean the
corona had a few questions that were
similar yeah but I know it's been
different sometimes it's business
sometimes corporate sometimes it's
entrepreneurial sometimes it's it's a
government sometimes it's health issues
sometimes it's spiritual issues
sometimes it's relationship issues it
depends on what the needs are under
human behavior that I get to be asked
and sometimes it's health related you
know has to do specials on cronin but no
I haven't had any excessive redundancies
it's been unique to the people that have
asked the question so I can't complain
Thanks right now in the health people be
in my twenties I'm 29 I've never been as
healthy as strong as fair and you know
you've been you've been an inspiration
to me as well so thanks thank you for
that thank you good well I'm going on 66
so I'll be 66 a few months when I saw
you speaking and I've got but I remember
thinking when I saw you speak I better
have that energy still when I'm in my
60s you know right now I can just rely
on being young got a naturally good
energy but actually if I carry on eating
bad and if I don't take my health
seriously if I'm just thinking about my
wealth and not my house what's gonna
happen is when I'm in my 40s or 50s at
some point I'm gonna feel really
different so it's inspiring seeing
people in their 60s they've got
incredible energy as well and that's
kind of what was a big part of me wanted
to you know get really getting shape and
get fit well when you do something you
love every day and you can't wait to get
up in the morning and do it I think you
you calm down the aging process a bit
yeah so I can't complain though I love
what I do and I do it every day and I've
delegated everything else I don't have a
lot of de-stresses because I've
delegated everything I've hired people
anything that I don't love doing I just
delegate to somebody else and I stick to
what I do which is research and teach
do interviews and private work with
people that's it so I don't I don't have
all the the things that bog people down
anymore don't tell they gave that away I
said I think you know I'm at a stage in
my life where I let other people do what
they love doing and I'll delegate the
things and find something that loves to
do what I want to delegate yeah outside
of teaching where where have you made
most where the members give you money
because I know you but most of my wealth
today is investment returns I mean what
do you investing that's a really that's
a really interesting topic at the moment
especially with what's happening with
the you know looking like we're
potentially going into a depression and
with the epidemic and everything's
changing what are you vested in and is
that changing right now
well I'm oh I'm defining an investment
as some product service or idea that
serves ever greater numbers of people
that is not a zero-sum game but a
nonzero-sum game sustainable fair
exchange that as population grows it
grows so for instance toilet paper is
something everybody's going to use for
them for as long as we're around to face
it's going to be something we're going
to use deodorant so anything that is a
service or a product that people will
use and the population will grow and
their brand names and their things that
are staples I buy companies that own
those companies that serve ever greater
numbers of people I'm not much into
speculation I buy quite diverse across
the sector's with indices I keep my cost
down my turnover down my costs down to
very low I reinvested dividends and I
just keep my cost down in my returns
high and I'm patient and I've been doing
it for 38 when I'm 38 years basically
and I've been very blessed by returns
the coronavirus I've made more money
during the coronavirus than ever in
history so I I knew that the market was
above the mean I was waiting for it to
go below the mean I put in a lot of cash
reserves in below the mean and it's come
back up and so I can't complain the pipe
I make sure that no matter what goes on
in the market I win I've structured my
portfolio and structured my investment
strategies to be where if he goes up I
win if it goes down I went it doesn't
matter where it goes you can win and I'm
not trying to make a fortune overnight
but I've made a fortune over time and
I'm a firm believer in investing in
quality companies that serve vast
numbers of people consistently and not
not something that's a the quickest get
rich system there's many of those I
passed by I
just a patient methodical tortoise
compared to the hare yeah I just keep I
keep buying quality companies that keep
serving people that are staples for
people if you help other people get what
they want to get life it helps you get
what you want to get life and that's
what a real investment is a speculation
is speculating with a crystal ball about
what you think is going to happen and
sometimes you win and sometimes you
don't and you're speculating on data
that's not really solid but when you
have a long track record at least 25
years as Charles Ellis says of a what a
mean would be and you're satisfied with
the mean and then you're expect less
than mean so you're evil for whatever
you get you patiently build up compound
interest which is one of the greatest
things you can ever get in your favor
and after a while that starts
multiplying and exceeding your active
income so I'm at the stage where I'm
blessed and not have to work I work the
purpose of financial independence is to
be able to make enough income where
you're not having to work you work
because you love to work so you're doing
something you love and getting paid for
it and then building momentum of
economics on top of that so that's and I
didn't start out that way I started out
saving a you know a dollar an hour $10 a
day
$50 a week $200 a month and then I just
kept increasing that every three months
and I increased it ten percent every
three months and I never stopped till it
was a quarter of a million dollars a
month and it was going in to savings and
investments and I just kept buying
companies and I bought real estate over
the time but I'm really more into
companies I understand companies better
than me dealing with real estate and
real estate has too many variables that
ties up too much capital it's too much
cash in and too many cost that are
unpredictable etc so I prefer to buy
companies myself I have had properties
many many properties over the years but
I've closed those now just so like Elon
Musk did this he realized the sinkholes
of of lifestyle and I keep a simple wise
time a very minimalist I keep a simple
lifestyle and a lot of investment money
he's interesting because going to a lot
of investors I've got a lot of money and
I think there's one right answer
everybody perspectives depending on what
you know and depending on if you invest
in stuff you don't know anything about
you know I'm a property guy I understand
property really really well in the UK
and I make good money in property in the
UK but then other people that don't know
anything about property but know a lot
about companies or know a lot about
maybe silver and gold or even crypto
currencies I don't understand
cryptocurrencies at all for me to invest
in crypto currencies would just be a
complete gamble a complete stop in the
dark property I know it's very safe
because I risk assess it I do my due
diligence properly I knew what I'm like
in the London School of Economics
there's a credit susi summary rating
that comes out of there every year it's
the greatest source of information on
investment probably in the world there's
a 120 year track record of documenting
every market in the world summarizing it
and I've watched that for many years and
I'm certain from looking at the stats
why I put my money where I do I've been
doing quite a bit of Studies on it now
like you say there's some people that
really love the real estate market and I
know some very wealthy people in the
real real estate market they bought in
quality properties they've invested it
they built land they developed it
they've put rental and commercial
properties together and they stacked it
on top of each other and they rebuilt
cities and done extraordinary things
some of the biggest wealth has come from
that but it also takes a bit of a focus
and I have to factor in the time thought
focus and the cost of that liabilities
of that and all that compared to what I
do so that's why I do it it's not that
mine right I just that's what works for
me based on what my needs are as a
speaker but I certainly know people and
I've spoken on many property investment
programs where they've made fortunes and
I encourage people to do it but I travel
full time I don't live anywhere and so I
like to make sure that I have access to
the liquidity that I do but but now I've
seen it where I
my limb ownership as you know the [ __ ]
was yeah so that's a very interesting
place to live
yeah I I am NOT there right now because
it's not available right now
yeah if they kind of docked it
temporarily until this thing passes but
there's some very wealthy people there
and there are some very smart people
there and many of them have been
property developers and built a fortune
through property
but like I said I have my preferences
because I understand businesses more so
than the property so I stick to I know
it's wise to stick to what you know the
cryptocurrencies I I didn't feel when I
investigated that they had a the way
they were set up on the blockchain of
the Mach mining I didn't think that was
a wise investment
not a bad for brokers to to buy and sell
but as far as holding that and doing
that I didn't think that had a long-term
future as well as buying quality
companies that serve people so I'd
rather be involved in serving people how
long have you been teaching how long
have you been kind of cause I mean when
I first got into the whole person world
investing world maybe 11 years ago you
one of the faces that you just know you
know you see you see your face
everywhere I haven't met you already
books but you were a very well-known
face in the whole industry how long has
that been the case I started teaching in
1973 so that's I guess 47 plus years now
and so I've been doing it a while I love
doing it
I started out where anybody who would
listen to me under a tree I gathered I
used to have 100 to 150 people gathered
under the tree every day and we do Q&A
and I had a philosophy session under a
tree and that grew into a cafeteria if
it rained and that grew into online and
not online but but daily programs in my
apartment and also wherever people would
allow me to come and speak be homes it
could be businesses it could be anywhere
I just took advantage of every
opportunity to share and it just grew
from local to eventually city to state
to nation to I now blessed to speak in
154 countries so I now with online we're
in every country with online but I mean
actually manually being in each
country's individual countries so it
started out as a dream when I was 17 and
it's become now my lifestyle and I
couldn't imagine
doing anything else other than what I
love doing which is researching and
teaching I'm writing a new book right
now and on labor not on astrophysics and
cosmology and so I'm also interested in
those topics and I'm interested in
helping human beings maximize their
human awareness and potential and help
them evolve their consciousness to do
something extraordinary planets we have
much in common in that respect but I've
been doing 47 years this will be 40 aged
already in November beginning of 48
oh they yeah I guess 48 Jim Rohn
impacted me when I was 20 I went to ask
him if he had a special student discount
on a package he had and he says don't
ever come to me and ask for a special
discount you're you're not a discount he
said don't ever come to my burden
without $200 in part because I made
tried to him dollars in their pocket
after that and I bought something I was
20 I he had a guy named he'll tell us
soon which hardly anybody knows about
but he was one of the most influential
Howard Hughes believed in not he had an
impact to me when I was to 14 Paul Bragg
had an impact and then I when I started
to read and overcome my learning
problems when I was 18 and started to
really to power there's been thousands
and thousands of great thinkers leaders
in different fields that have now been
mentors I've been blessed to meet a lot
of people that have influenced probably
three thousands of something people of
influence in the world and so I've been
mentored by many different people you
know talking to them breaking bread
asking questions skyping meetings many
people there's no one and there's a lot
of people a lot to teach say talk about
all kind of things how do you separate
the the real deal the people are like
yeah they probably got some I can learn
from and someone who's perhaps not quite
so genuine that's just jumping on the
bandwagon trying to be a trainer to make
you Bob
sometimes I've learned from all of them
things to do or not to do but I I'm more
interested in people that are involved
in philanthropy than debauchery and just
because they're wealthy doesn't mean if
they're doing something wrong Ives so
I'm not necessary just because they have
money because I know people that just
squander their money on lifestyle
instead of contribution I'm more
interested in people that are involved
in contribution but I this morning I got
a call from a music real company that's
involved in interviewing musicians and
famous musicians they have to think it
didn't be me so I sometimes will do an
interview and sometimes I'll be on with
amazing people in the interview on
panels or whatever and that's how I
start the ball meeting people or going
on a TV show and meeting people you run
into the band there or you run into a
celebrity there I've just been blessed
to run into the right people at the
right time to interact in ways that have
opened up many doors and I just keep you
know if you just relentlessly pursue
what it is that you love doing which in
my case is sharing ideas soon later you
build a momentum and build a brand
around it and people start recognizing
it and then you influence people of
influence and then they contact you and
then you end up having a mr. consults
through something and it just keeps on
unfolding longer you do it I mean what
when you're my age what you'll do will
be astounding you know you're already
doing it so what it will be will be more
astounding because it's just gonna keep
building momentum like a ball running
downhill picking up so ball picking up
snow as he goes you won't be able to you
may not even see when in fact you're
going to have but if you stay with it
and never stop the impact will be
extraordinary so you'll you'll you'll
stand on my shoulders and do something
much greater that's just that's
inevitable I'll definitely receive that
I'll receive that what do you think you
most want to inform when I think of dr.
John Demartini I think probably of
topics around purpose finding purpose my
methodology are dissolving emotional
internal conflicts and getting clear
about what's inspiring to you and your
mission isn't the Train
form human perception is probably the
most significant thing that I've
contributed the work on values that I've
done is is impacting the world is really
going and spreading all over the world
now I think also in some of the areas
that I just personal transformation
human transformation has probably been
the cornerstone of what I'm doing but
I've been blessed to be involved in all
kinds of things I mean I like I said Ben
I got to be blessed to be in a movie
coming up that's gonna be with Stephen
Hawking on astrophysics I worked in
mathematics I'm what they call a
polymath that I've worked in many
different fields and I've been blessed
to interact with all kinds of people in
many fields so but the ultimate
objective of all of my studies and
learning is all about the evolution the
consciousness maximizing that awareness
potential to help people do something
extraordinary in planet earth and to
live a purposeful meaningful and
inspired life yeah the secret to
happiness
I don't pursue happiness and the
classical hedonistic perspective I'm
more interested in the Aleut emmonak
perspective where fulfillment means
something to me happiness and sadness
are like polarities of transit miss I'm
more interested in realizing that the
the two sides of the polarities are both
feedback systems to get you authentic
down the center so I'm more interested
in the center path than the momentary
transient smiles or frowns happy zorse
adds polarities I'm orange devil minute
I'm a man on a mission I'm not a man not
labeled and success or failure I'm more
into the man on a mission and I embrace
both of those I always say the second
you think you're successful you're d
purposing the second think you're a
failure you're repurposing but if you
just stand purpose you don't get
distracted by either of those illusions
how are we going to go not me but how is
just general people especially people
that haven't necessarily but gardens and
haven't got necessarily got families
that are on their own how people going
to cope are we going to fall into
depression of the mind how do you think
what what effect do you think hasn't a
lot of business owners that them welcome
active in you know really honed in on
their businesses of profited like you
have over the last few months what kind
of effect do you think is had on
humanity well depends on the individual
you know it's it's never what happens on
the outside it's what you decide to do
with your controlling only three things
in your life perception decisions and
actions you don't have control in the
world around you as much as you have the
control of your perception decisions and
actions around them
so if you take the so called thing
around you and ask how specifically can
I use this to my greatest advantage
how's that helping me fulfill my mission
and answer that question and see the
upsides to what you think is a downside
it's not a downside it's neutral so I
don't if somebody comes to me and
running waiting to run their story as a
victim of history I stopped them in the
middle of story and said I'm not the guy
if you want to run a story you go to a
therapist for that if you wanted
transform your life then stop the story
and let's find out how this thing is
actually helping you get what you want
and find out how it's on the way not in
the way and the moment they do they
change the story because the stories
most stories of emotions are usually
incomplete by asking question houses
helping you get what you want and make
them stop and go I never thought about
that well how is it helping you never
thought about it well think about it
how's it helping you how can you use it
to your greatest advantage what's the
opportunity of sitting in front of you
and when they do that they find it and
then they turn it into opportunity so
it's just a matter of the attitude
William James said the greatest
discovery of his generation see human
beings can alter their lives by altering
their perceptions and attitudes of mind
so true if we take the time to change
our perceptions and then if we make a
decision to change our actions and go to
high priority actions and ask what is
the highest priority action I can do
today to help you fulfill my mission on
earth and so the greatest number of
people with the most sustainable fair
exchange way to earn the greatest income
so I can then delegate so I can stay on
the high priorities again if I do that
and ask that question and see things on
the way and ask priorities
there's no way what's happening on the
outside is gonna stop you from doing
what is inspiring to you on the inside
yeah yeah but you don't describe
yourself as opposed to thinking idea
no I think that's misleading I'm a
balanced thinker because if you're if
you're seeing only the upsides it's like
being in fatuous something you're
unconscious to the downsides and you're
blinded by it you get smacked cuz you're
fantasy you're going on a fantasy if
you're on the downsides and you're
depressed is because you're comparing
yourself to a fantasy again I'd look for
both sides if I was to go to you and I
said you're always up never down always
positive never negative always kind
never cruel always peaceful never
wrathful always giving never taking it
you would your [ __ ] meter would go
off and you go not always if I spend
you're always mean and never nice and
with the other way you'd go [ __ ] no
but if I said sometimes or this
sometimes you're that sometimes you're
positive sometimes you know you're
something you go yeah well so white suit
shoots for something that's one-sided
when it doesn't have a reality so I'm a
firm believer that I look for both sides
of life is that way I'm prepared in
advance for the challenges that I
normally would blind myself to by
pursuing once items I have a really
important s it's because being a
positive thing yeah which you said no
you wanna be a balance think yeah and
looking for the opportunity and
everything well with every opportunity
if somebody gives you an opportunity and
you're elated about it and you're having
a fantasy and you're excited and you're
out extroverted and telling well I got
this amazing opportunity but that
usually means you're blind to the
downsides the challenges and all the
work that's going to take to handle it
so what I do is I believe it's wise to
keep your mind centered balanced find
out and mitigate the risks in advance I
always think it's wise to ask what
obstacles might I run into and how do I
solve in a bit you don't make it to Mars
you don't make it to the space station
the other day with a lawn muss you don't
make it a space station without asking a
lot of questions like what if this
happens what will I do what if this
happens what will I do and mitigate all
the anxieties so you're clear and now
you have the benefits of what you're
going to do you know the drawbacks are
prepared for both now instead of
reacting you're proactive so I'm a firm
believer in meditating on those
so-called downsides in advance
clear them out so you're now either
we've you know preventing them or
knowing what to do if they happen so
your minds not distracted with
uncertainties and emotions and then
focus on your chief aim
don't get into a fantasy about how it's
gonna be only one-sided because that's
not the case yeah that make sense what's
happening then John right now what's
going on with all this epidemic we've
got the black lives matter movement
we've got the protests we've got the
corona we don't know whether we're
allowed in but we're allowed out what's
what's gonna happen what's your
perspective on this because I think a
lot of people are freaking out right now
well I mean every every so often every
so many centuries or decades or what we
have sometimes years we have you know
epidemics or in this case a pandemic and
that happens and there's a there'll be
some some loss of life and there'll be
some empowered mewn systems and we'll
learn new things about biology and new
things about the immune system and new
things about society and we'd grow and
life has challenges and every time we
face a challenge as Bucky fuller says
pollution is future solution every time
we have a challenge we come up with new
innovative creative ideas and we come
and concretely go on to the next
challenge so this is a temporary
challenge it's not gonna stop human
beings it's going to be a temporary
little glitz for some people only
because they haven't seen the time and
adapted I always say the inability to
adapt to a changing environment is
what's called distress and distress
comes from the perception of loss of
that which you see to the perception of
gain of that what you're trying to avoid
if you're trying to avoid something and
seek the fantasy a lot of people are
depressed because they're comparing
their current reality not to reality but
comparing it to a fantasy how it used to
be in a fantasy about how it's going to
but it should have been and they're not
present with what it is and then when
they're present with what is this how is
this helping me get what I want then the
depressions gone the pressure was a
feedback to let you know that you're
expecting fantasies and unrealistic
expectations so whatever is happening
right now as far as I'm concerned it's
it's going to strengthen human beings
and make them more innovative and
creative and the online world has just
been boosted we've all become more
efficient
I mean Amazon has boomed the old
dinosaur type of businesses are going
out that's not anything but normal
evolution
and that's before people that had
foresight are gonna boom the people that
had hindsight are gonna bust that's the
way it is that's the way the evolution
of consciousness works and so I don't
see anything out there except a normal
evolution we just had a new challenge
it's something we get to take in but we
will actually learn more about the
immune system more about physiology
health psychology a business it's only
going to make us more efficient and
effective in the future yeah and how do
you become the kind of company that can
have good full sides that have just
hindsight how do you become the kind of
company that knows because we keep
hearing people talking about you need to
adapt you to adapt how do you have those
girls how do you develop those skills
it's very simple
and it's so simple people over looking
if you ask yourself what is the highest
priority action I can do today to help
me fulfill my mission on earth that'll
serve the greatest number of people in
the most effective and efficient way in
a way that inspires myself and the
people and you keep to the priority the
blood-glucose an auction goes into the
forebrain the forebrain has fibers that
go from the medial prefrontal cortex
into the visual cortex to get vision it
goes into the areas that deal with
probabilities of risk reward and
innovation and it gives an execution and
it governs the amygdala to stop the
impulses and instincts if you live by
priority you wake in fourth sight if you
live not by priority you live by
hindsight and people by hindsight go
extinct and people with foresight move
for it they're the ones that are
resilient they're more objective than
we're reasonable they can see things
they're prepared for things that they're
more balanced in their orientation
they're willing to embrace challenge
they seek challenge instead of avoid it
and the people that are not they're back
in their amygdala trying to avoid
predator and see prey and they're in a
in an impulse instinct center they're
the ones that give in to extinct
all animals do go extinct over time
that's been proven 99.9% of all species
I've ever lived on the planet gone
it's the people that have resilience and
adaptability that live with foresight to
keep moving on and develop technology as
a way of fulfilling teleology the
mission and purpose of their lives to be
able to be that kind of business
and that's what if the other by priority
your life is going to go that way I
don't if you don't feel your day with
high priority actions inspire you it's
going to fill up with low priority
distractions attempt it's that simple
that if you don't feel your day with
things that are deeply meaningful it's
gonna fill up in things that are
meaningless that's why if you don't have
if you earn money without meaning you
end up with debauchery
that's why it's so important to find
something that's extremely meaningful a
legacy you want to create on the planet
to build your wealth for to serve people
for to be of med to be a meaning because
that's the thing that makes us different
than the animals is meaning we can all
look for pleasure but pleasures
transient meaning is something
fulfilling and meaning is not something
that's universally available as chemist
says meaning is what we make out of
things based on finding out how
whatever's happening in our life how is
it helping us for so much deeply
important to us so do you think being
successful is it about hard work or they
just about didn't annoying things Oh
bother
it's a combination of both I've not seen
one individual that's done extraordinary
things without putting mailboat grease
into it and doing the work yeah
when somebody tells you they've got a
4-hour workweek I laughs yeah I've never
seen anybody do anything with a 4-hour
workweek that I mean maybe after they
built something from thousands of hours
of work in there now there's something
they decided that they've lost their
mission but people on a mission work
harder I agree with that 100% I don't I
I work seven days a week I don't I don't
think anything of 18-hour day nothing
that doesn't even think about and people
that why would you do something tell you
don't have to do that yeah because I
found something that's deeply meaningful
and I love doing and that's what
inspires me I love doing what I do it
when people find that the average person
has a Monday morning blues Wednesday
Hope days thank God it's Friday sand
week friggin ants and they basically
live for a break a holiday and escape in
her retirement you don't need that
sanity he doesn't realize when you're in
a job when I was just working hard in a
job and not any passive income enough
properties and I thought if I just had
to
thousand pounds a month coming in from
rental income I didn't have to work oh
my goodness
I just want to lie on a beach and relax
but actually when it happens we're not
we're not designed we're not created to
do that we're creating designed to do
something much more and then people say
to me sometimes now you know if you're
making good money in property why do we
teach what's the purpose and they I
understand why they think that I used to
think that I said you know why is this
person teaching business and speaking on
stages if they've made money in business
and now if someone that's made a lot of
money in property I totally get it
because life would be boring as anything
to just be on a meet benign mind-numbing
I'm in a position where I don't have to
work I could live on a couple million
dollars a year passively doing nothing
but what death that's death yeah I would
much rather go and do what we're doing
right now and try to make some sort of
contribution any day of the week because
anybody I've asked thousands of people
millions of people if you had the
opportunity to make a difference in
somebody's lives and you actually you
know then they say thank and you've made
some sort of contribution how many beer
agrees that's what's meaningful they all
put their hands up I said so why would
you want to life anything else why would
you want to take a break from your life
why not find something you have no
desire to take a break from and fill
your life for that to me that makes more
sense so I'm a firm believer that and
I've structured my life so I can do that
this is what I love learning and
teaching I didn't I was thinking I was
thinking maybe it's round by your
company but you wouldn't personally be
there but I'll go anyway I'm gonna love
the stuff and then when you came in I
thought oh wow dr. John Ziemann he's
actually here and it's a fantastic time
we had and then I brought some family
and friends with me the second time
having any plans to come back to the UK
anyone knew when that's going to be or
is just all depending on the law well
I'm actually coming in online yeah well
that I was gonna ask you about that as
well but the days I'm gonna be getting
up at 2:00 in the morning here and
speaking
all dated migrate to experience I'll get
up at 2:00 starting here which we ate
there and we'll go to about 10:00 or
11:00 at night there which will be
whatever it is here six hours four
o'clock I think or five online program
for people live online program I'll be
doing it this weekend and then I'll be
doing that on and it's my the one that
I've done one thousand one hundred and
this will be one thousand one hundred
and one times absolutely amazing and
what about as well if people don't see
these interview time for that let's see
this after the event programs every week
I'm doing programs every week I mean
yeah every day in fact so if they go
online and look at my website and look
under events that will give you whether
it's live events or online events and
also of my Facebook where I'm doing
Facebook things my youtubes but if you
go to my website dr. DiMartino um you
can probably first of all you can go and
do a value determination to find out
what's really important to you in your
life which is a goldmine to doing
Freed's
compliments private takes thirty minutes
of your time you just gotta answer with
integrity now you can go on my website
and spend the rest of your life on there
there's enough material to keep you busy
for rest of your life thousands of radio
shows podcast interviews events live
things products you can be there for
mister your life it's a good place to
hang around because I'm always refreshed
inspired educate material what are the
top three best things about the
breakthrough experience program well
instead of subordinating and conforming
to the world on the outside
the breakthrough experience is about you
discovering what your true mission is on
the inside and what is it you really
want to bring to the world and what
exactly is it that you perceive that you
are seeing in the way and show you how
to turn it on the way so there's no
friction there's fuel to go on and do
something extorting with your left the
brakes are experience I've been doing
for 32 years almost I mean I got a good
track record one thousand one hundred
and now one times coming up
hundreds of thousands of people into
this this thing so it's it's for people
that one in power I or say that if
you're not empowering yourself
intellectually you'll be told what to
think you're not in powering yourself in
business you'll be told what to do if
you're not empowering yourself in
finance should be told what you're worth
if you're not empowering yourself in
relationship you'll be told what to do
around the house if you're not
empowering yourself socially you'll be
told propaganda misinformation if you're
not important so physically be told what
drugs to take an Oregon story with if
you're not empowering yourself
spiritually you told some dogma that
antiquated that is actually misleading
with opium but if you actually go in and
power your life you're the one that sets
the stage you live by design not default
you live by an inspiration instead of
desperation and the break to experience
is about people that are willing to get
on seriously with me coming master of
and leader of their lives it's not a
rah-rah session it's not a hype session
it's not a dancing and standing on
chairs and listen to music stuff if you
want to do that don't come to my program
that's for people that want rah rah and
heard funds I'm interested in helping a
person go through and summarize the
forty-seven to almost forty eight years
of my research on what maximizes human
behavior and gives people the
competitive ahead advantage to go do
something extraordinary their life and
delivering that in a practical way that
they can go home and start applying it
and make a difference in their lives
that's what break is about it's about
breaking through and you ever you
perceive is in the way turning it on
yeah one last question instead we're
going to ask this but as we've met and
this is the first time you've been on my
youtube channel you've met me up with
you well you won't be your best piece of
advice specifically to Maine from the
little you know about me is there
anything you can say to me which would
be helpful encouraging if so I'd love to
hear the same thing I tell everybody and
how to simply stay focused on what's
highest in priority stick to what your
core competences start with what you
know and let what you know grow and as
what is the highest priority action you
can do each day that can help you serve
the greatest number of people in your
mission and if you stick to priority
it's impossible for you not to build
momentum and achieve something amazing
in this planet
a really powerful really impeccable to
everybody listening I'm gonna leave in
the description on this channel a link
to dr. John Dean martinis website go
check it out John I've really appreciate
you coming on the channel again I hope
to see you soon whether it be online or
whether it be in person hopefully as
well in the UK in the US and most likely
it'll be there probably by September
would probably be something out in there
I'm in Houston Texas of all places
Houston Texas baby boy that's nice [ __ ]
well no I'm I'm rarely in Houston
normally but since Coronas been I've
been here for a while my kids are here
so my kids are grown up but I'm a handy
opportunity to interact with them a
little bit more because they you know
they're grown up and have their own
lives now but I I am I've been here for
a while now and it's been extraordinary
because I'm just able to focus you know
my 18 hours plus days doing what I love
doing which is researching and teaching
and doing interviews like yourself so
thank you for helping me fulfill my
mission I appreciate it thank you so
much speech you say John must he said